alors les milieux les plus plébiscités
au monde
mais pour une demande en mariage arrive
en première position j'ai trouvé ça
complètement d'orgue disneyland paris
dans le bel accueil enfants amaechi
assez d'accord vous allez vous vous
feriez votre demande à l'entrée entre
mickey dingo
c'est quoi qu'elle demande en mariage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la princesse extraordinaire d'accord moi
je voyais truc un peu avec bon ben on va
juste après on reste toujours pour dire
à disney world mais en floride
ensuite celle minnesota avec les les
parcs un peu magnifie la tour eiffel
quand même qui arrive en quatrième
position et e.on descends descends
descends et ont fini pour le 10e c'est
bondi beach à sydney qui semble-t-il est
magnifique paraît que c'est très sympa
vous ne feriez votre demande ont d'abord
est ce que vous estimez que c'est à
l'homme de faire sa demande
mais pas du tout mais pas du tout et je
ne compte alors je comprends pas du tout
que cette histoire de trucs mais ces
annonces mais c'est pas ta position
c'est pas à toi de faire normalement
attend que je fasse la demande
moi je trouve ça génial vous avez fait
votre demande vous alors oui il m'avait
jamais ça marié la gg je me sens pas de
me remarier mais si tenté que ça me
passe par la tête
non ce serait ma demande comment ça non
non il est bon lui non je suis pas
d'accord non mais je leur accorde aux
dix premiers à montrer l'avancée de la
gale en prie de faire en sorte que ça
soit l'homme qui demande la façade est
bien ensuite alors ça va non même
bannière gueule avec ça non mais avec sa
petite jupe crayon dont j'aimerais bien
l'avoir mettre un genou à terre et
quelques ados elle va m'offrir
je plonge je
[Applaudissements]
crayon regarder ce qu'elle veut lancer
un genou à terre bien sûr jean michel et
catherine feriez vous de me prendre pour
épouse légitime et ses fumées répondre
non je laisse moi réfléchir à un ou deux
ans est ce que vous comprenez mais en
moi que ces messieurs parfois se disent
franchement c'est encore un bastion
qu'elle nous prennent
c'était l'endroit de la virilité c'était
moi le chevalier servant c'était à moi
de faire la demande
elle m'a super lap réunion mais n'en
bastia veulent demander en mariage
qu'est ce qu'on vous a demandé en
mariage vous on m'a demandé en mariage
une fois oui elle est bien vague
[Applaudissements]
vous savez à quel point ce musée mais
que je vous trouve charmant oui mais non
vous avez dit non bah oui j'ai dit non
même si non pourquoi j'ai dit non parce
que moi le mariage franchement ça me
fais pas tu fais du coup j'étais
célibataire après mais non mais non mais
moi je ne comprends pas c'est un truc
qui m'échappe mais si vous êtes d'accord
c'est à dire ça coûte de l'argent à
l'aller ça coûte de l'argent en retour
[Rires]
et le romantisme tout ça non mais le
romantisme da comme on n'a pas besoin
d'être mariée pour ça moi je vis très
bien avec une personne et puis voilà je
mets quand mes poumons aaron victoire de
toute façon que voilà ça va je vais pas
aller trop molle comme disait coluche
c'est comme les accidents il ya des
témoins et tout pour le mariage alors
bon emilie je vous sais faisait c'est
une femme qui pose qui pose donc est
dans le coup très bien nous enfin ma
compagne m'a fait la demande en mariage
il ya sept ans et demi il va falloir y
aller la banane trop c'est trop dans
merde de se marier vraiment c'est nous
qu'on se dispute pour nous on va le
faire
combien de personnes vont inviter les
passants 0 10e je vais faire ça
calmement ah non non non non vous
connaissez deux ans et demi quand même
vous avouer qu'elle est un petit peu
voilà oui mais voilà ils veulent et
c'est un peu la laisser faire c'est
l'envi non non non quand elle a fait la
demande c'était l'endroit on a eu notre
premier rendez-vous pour noir moi donc
ça c'est raconter une histoire par
exemple si vous ne deviez refaire une
demande ce serait où pour l'allemand
moi je pense que je le ferai à la
montagne je trouve ça très beau j'avais
somme est d'accord là haut tout là ouvre
dans les étoiles vous à au soleil ah bah
oui et on peut rajouter tooway une plage
on peut tout nu ce serait formidable
vous faites votre demande tout nouveau
tout poil en recense construit le site
quand il va mettre un genou à terre il
ya un truc on a fait le tour du sujet on
est bien d'accord
je vois quand même qu'on a quatre
champions du romantisme demande leur
compagnon mariage j'adore ou bien c'est
à l'homme de j'adore pour 71 pour 29 %
c'est encore à l'homme de le faire
racontez-nous vos demandes en mariage et
vos mariages éventuellement on adore
lire ça nous ça va être formidable ça
met notre lecture romantique de tout à
l'heure